well it is completely wide open to talk
about that with me in the studio is
Henning Eureka head of the transatlantic
relations program at the German Council
of Foreign Relations good morning thanks
for being with us honey these midterms
are getting far more attention here in
Europe than midterms in the u.s. usually
do what's what's behind that I think
it's because we're so puzzled by who
Donald Trump is and how he acts the very
disruptive policies the pressure on the
allies in Europe the possible damage he
does to the political system in the US
so we are wondering how he can survive
this kind of like different approach in
policy his own policy style partly
erratic partly strategic in a certain
way to to improve the position of
America in the world as he says without
possibly doing it so it's interesting
for us and we wonder whether checks and
balances work whether the political
system in America is working and whether
he is now getting a tighter control and
oversight from Congress with new
majorities possible on Trump has been
under constant criticism here in Germany
from members of all parties since he's
taken office since he's been in office
over the last two years what a shift in
the balance of power in Congress towards
the Democrats improve relations between
the United States and Germany with that
in mind I wouldn't think so we would
possibly gain a bit more trust in the
checks and balances system and then
trust in the in the leading democracy
but it's hard to foresee how how Trump
would react would he if he had if you
would see his own legislative agenda
blocked his own is almost project
blocked by Congress would he then step
up the sort of internal civil war that
he's starting the inflammatory rhetoric
the the polarization that he's using to
to reach out to his base because he's
what he wants to be reelected into in
2020 or will he look for like foreign
theaters and and star wars to the
outside which is not so easy he's also a
price worse to the outside that that's
quite a claim I mean he's he's stepping
up the escalation with Iran
he has embraced the North Korean leader
but it really opened whether this would
lead to denuclearization I don't I don't
see that that that Donald Trump is
looking for failures in his foreign
policy he wants to be the strong man he
wants to do to be seen as somebody who
gets things done and he doesn't want to
go into failure so so he might pick his
enemies well at that point in time this
might also mean for us for you far for
us Europeans and that he's trying to
squeeze out more for the u.s. and in
terms of trade relations or in terms of
burden sharing in NATO and that is a
more a more plausible scenario okay so
should the Democrats take power there is
a very real concern in Europe the Donald
Trump could become more active on the
foreign policy front and that would
include dismantling some of the global
institutions he's very much opposed to
as part of what he calls us anti
globalist agenda on on trade and and
NATO do you see that as you mentioned as
being a real threat it is it is a threat
but when you look at what what the
Americans do they support Native they've
spent more money for defence and
deterrence in the UN they are skeptical
about certain certain Orient's but
they're not withdrawing completely so
there will be a reshift a reshuffling of
resources from from the American side
and a lot of bad rhetoric but I think on
base the Europeans have people in
America to work with so heading rika
head of the transatlantic relations
program as the German Council on Foreign
Relations thanks very much you're
welcome